- [Narrator] We are
now going to talk about
what is perhaps the most
important macro molecule in life,
and that is known as nucleic acid.
Now first of all where
does that name come from?
Well scientists first
observed this in the nucleus
of cells and so that's where
you get the nucleic part.
And it has some acidic properties
and so that's where you get the acid part.
And perhaps the most
famous of the nucleic acids
is deoxyribonucleic acid or DNA for short.
And we'll go into some
depth in this as we go
through our journey in biology,
but you might already know
that this is the molecule
that stores our hereditary information.
This DNA, to a large
degree, makes you you.
And it's known as a macro molecule,
and we've talked about macro
molecules in other videos,
we've talked about carbohydrates,
and we have talked about proteins.
And DNA is a macro molecule
because it can be made of
many millions of atoms.
Just to get a sense of it,
you can see right over here,
the double helix of DNA,
where you have one side
of your helix right over
there and then another one
right over here and then
you kind of have these rungs
of this twisted ladder.
A DNA molecule, let's
say in the human genome,
a chromosome, for example,
is primarily a really long DNA molecule.
And they can have on the
order of a hundred million
rungs to this ladder.
Now another thing to appreciate
like many other macro
molecules, DNA, or
nucleic acids in general,
they are polymers in that
they're made up of building block
molecules and those building
blocks for nucleic acids
and DNA is the most famous nucleic acid
and RNA, Ribonucleic acid
would be a close second.
But the building blocks of
them are known as nucleotides.
Nucleotides.
And we see some examples
of nucleotides over here.
This is deoxyadenosine monophosphate,
which would be a nucleotide found in DNA.
You can see the various parts of it.
You have a phosphate
group right over here.
You have a five carbon sugar,
which in this case, is ribose.
And then you have what is
known as a nitrogenous base.
And why is it called nitrogenous?
Well all those blue
circles represent nitrogen
and we've seen this before,
the grays are carbons.
And the reds are oxygens
and the whites hydrogens.
And so this part of the molecule
has some basic characteristics.
While this phosphate group at the end this
has some acidic characteristics.
And what happens is they
get stacked onto each other
where the ribosephosphates
alternate to form
the backbone of this DNA molecule.
You can see it right over here
where you have a phosphate and a ribose
and a phosphate and a ribose.
And then you have the
nitrogenous base forming
part of the rung of the ladder.
And the way that DNA
stores information is,
every one of these nitrogenous
bases right over here
this is adenine, it has a
complimentary nitrogenous base
on the other to complete
that rung of the ladder.
So adenine matches with thiamine and DNA
and we'll see in future videos in RNA,
it's a nitrogenous base known as urasil,
and guanine matches with cytosine.
Don't worry too much about this now,
we'll go into some depth
in this in future videos
when we talk about DNA and how
information is stored in it.
But for the sake of this
video, just appreciate
that the monomer for a nucleic acid
like DNA is a nucleotide.
So monomer, and to be very
clear, this would not be
the only monomer, the
analogous nucleotide in RNA,
which stands for ribonucleic acid would be
adenosine monophosphate right over here.
You can see the difference between the two
that we have an oxygen right over here,
and we don't have an
oxygen right over here.
That's why this is
called deoxy, and that's
why it's deoxyribonucleic acid.
You're missing one of those oxygens
on your five carbon sugar.
But adenine as I mentioned is
not the only nitrogenous base.
You could have a nucleotide
where the nitrogenous base
is thiamine, and so once
again, this looks very similar
but notice what is going on over here.
You could have a nucleotide
that looks like this.
Once again, you have your
five carbon sugar here,
you have your phosphate group,
but the nitrogenous base
here keeps on changing.
And it's the order of
these different nucleotides
that actually encodes
the information in DNA.
Now one question you
might say is, well look,
if I have this part of
the molecule that has
basic characteristics, why
is it considered an acid?
Well look at how this
molecule is structured.
The basic parts form the
rungs of this ladder.
So they're not going to be as reactive
because they're really
tied, they're closer
to the inside of the molecule
while the acidic parts,
the phosphate groups are on the outside.
So they're going to be more reactive.
And so the molecule as
a whole is going to have
an acidic characteristic.
I'm going to leave you there.
In future videos we're going to go into
a lot more depth in the
importance of nucleic acid,
especially DNA and RNA.
And to just appreciate how
amazing these molecules are.
Some folks theorize that
the first signs of life
were nothing more than
self-replicating RNA molecules
that eventually got enclosed
in some type of membrane
structures, which eventually
started forming the
genetic machinery of a cell etc, etc, etc.
So this is why these
nucleic acids are sometimes
considered the most fundamental
macromolecules to life.